[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today we're
talking about a video that we saw
recently which we we will show you guys
here in a second but the perfect person
to talk about this was walking by Ken
Coleman yeah I got the bat signal it's
very ex K come in here and join us for
this segment because there was a video
that was published was it was it
Bloomberg
that maybe Business Insider do you guys
know I mean it was just
everywhere was a Tik Tok video of a
young girl um we're going to say jiny
mhm yeah and she was
struggling with the reality of what
working full-time meant uh oh and how it
felt 9 to5 9 to5 the exhaustion so let's
go ahead and uh Play Play that video
sweet girl I know I'm probably just
being so dramatic and annoying but this
is my first job like my first 9 to5 job
after college and I'm in person and I'm
commuting in the city and it takes me
forever to get get there there's no way
I'm going to be able to afford living in
the city right now so that's off the
table like if I was able to walk to work
it it'd be fine but I'm not so it
literally takes me like I leave here
like I get on the train at 7:30 and I
don't get home till like 6:15 earliest
and then like I don't have time to do
anything I don't I want to shower eat my
dinner and go to sleep I don't have time
or energy to cook by dinner either like
I don't have energy to work out like
that's out the window like I'm so upset
oh my God
nothing to do with my job at all but
just like the 9 to5 schedule in general
is crazy being in the office 9 to5 like
if it was remote you get off at 5:00 and
you're home and everything's fine but
like I'm not home it takes me long to
get home and like like people that drive
to the office like it doesn't you don't
get off at 5: and I know it could be
worse I know I could be working longer
but like I literally get off it's pitch
black like I don't have energy how do
you have friends like how do you have
time to like meet like a guy I don't
know like how do you have time for like
dating like I don't have time for
anything and I'm like so stressed out I
just want to hug
her okay first things first she gets
home around 6:15 and all she has time
for is eating and showering I want to
know how long of a shower she's Tak does
she have kids that's a long shower like
do you have kids no she has no concept
of time I don't have time to work out to
see boys it's 6:15 what are you doing
wait though wait though Ken cuz I kind
of there were parts of me that kind of
felt what she was saying a little bit
what part because I've always worked
from home I've always run business from
home which means like you get the you
have the ability to tweak your schedule
very easily you don't have to ask
anybody if I say I'm going to start my
day at 9:00 a.m. or if Tuesday I go I
got to take my daughter to daycare I'm
going to start my day at 10:00 a.m. and
then I'm going to come back at 900 p.m.
and make up that hour I can do that but
when you when you have a 9 to-5 job it's
like no you're here from 9 to 5 that is
your block so it is a lot less freedom
in that way and when I took this job it
was my first 9 to five I I felt this
shellshock like I was like oh wow this
is a big block of time I've always
blocked my time in smaller chunks you're
very sweet that you what you're saying
it's not the same as what she's saying
it's not the same when she gets home at
6:15 all she has time for is a shower
and maybe a quick microwave meal she
really saying no
the what she's really saying is she's
weak no this is a weak-minded young girl
no K she struggling she said I like my
job but if I lived in the city and I
could walk there I'd be fine the whole
meltdown was about her time from 6:15
until bedtime and she didn't account for
the 4 hours thus this is a young girl
who's very kind if you're used to more
hours a meltdown on Tik to it is a
meltdown but if you are used to more
hours in your day that you can spend the
way you choose I but she it it does feel
like this is her first job though it's
it's she is reacting to like oh my gosh
I just get like this is AD Hood this is
adulthood thank you it's adult but let
me say this I remember I remember waking
up probably like 4 months into work
after college okay coming here and
thinking like oh my gosh like this is my
this is my life this is my life for the
next four 40 years or however long like
every point up until then there's a
transition right Elementary School to
Middle School to high school there's
something new and and you wake up in
this like daunting adult brain where you
think this is okay this is my life
forever and I remember getting home
watching Wheel of Fortune at 6:30 and at
7:00 I was tired no I wasn't on Tik Tok
crying like I knew like I have bills to
pay like we have to work we're adults
here but I do think it is tired think so
you're tired please tell me you're tired
you get you're tired 100% last night my
two teenage boys were out of the house
with friends Josie our our youngest had
a a friend upstairs I was in the living
room watching the football game and
completely snoring to in between like
wake so I get it that's not what this
video is about this video is hold on a
second you guys think I'm so mean I'm
not you're you're being Kendy the kend
when since when did having Common Sense
make you a kudin then guilty as char
because this gal is freaking out over
the amount of time she has between
getting home from work and going to bed
that's what this is about she is
freaking out but she also could be
learning something about how she's she
could be I'm not saying she is she could
be learning something about how she's
what she's bent towards cuz I do think
some people are more bent towards I can
go to a 9 to5 job I can punch my clock I
can be there from whatever 8 to 4 95
whatever and it doesn't bother me and I
get used to it fine and then other
people are like I need need to work for
myself I need to be able to set my
schedule I need to be able to start and
stop she could be like oh my gosh if
this is the world like I can't do it she
could be doing that all right let me
take another I think take another angle
but but but even Jade let me say this
not against this girl I'm ready for
another angle but okay but but I'm just
saying if you had to and didn't have a
choice you got to work yeah you wouldn't
necessarily probably be melting down
here's an idea you're saying if she if
she had no other options and this is
what she had to
do you you there's a gum like you you
would have to find that inner strength
she doesn't have another option you got
to work yeah right you got work let me
let me take another tag okay all right
let me just not be a kudan for a second
all right let me let me put on I think
most of America is probably agreeing
with you we're playing devil almost
always do but anyway here's the thing
let me take the caring dad hat for a
moment okay take the caring dad I
understand sweetheart this is a real
shock to your system all the things that
sister J and sister Rachel said they
love you they're your older sister
sister or sister you would be sister
with a uh or an A only I get it here's
the point if you're struggling like this
call your
friend uh listen to a Taylor Swift song
stop uh talk to Mom and Dad don't go on
Tik Tok and melt down stop with to share
every obno cuz let me tell you something
I got some crazy thoughts in my head I
don't want any to know I sure is H
double hockey stick I'm not going on Tik
Tok going I'm wildly insecure and I'm ex
and I'm melting down well let me just
tell you I edited some things out that
were even more personal so that's I
edited some things out that were even
more personal so that was the edited
version that's right you did I have seen
and I know yes so what I'm saying is as
the dad can we stop sharing our souls on
Tik Tok now that kin is very good very
we all deserve chance to melt down yes
but for God's sake do it in private with
your with a friend with somebody safe
get with Jesus now we're talking about
this poor girl on a huge show and I
don't I don't I don't mean her any ill
will at all cuz I'd actually go oh I
want to give you a hug I get it life is
hard this does suck yeah either move
into the city later when you could
afford it or let's get a job where we
don't have to commute cuz commuting is a
real stress I I don't want to in any way
minimize the commute but you know look
you get home at 6:15 maybe you don't
take a 3-hour shower I don't know maybe
or maybe you work out at 5 maybe eat on
the train maybe get up at 5:30 work out
I I don't know lots of things do there's
a way to do it and I will say this after
having multiple children sitting here
all of us yes we probably can adjust
more by the way kid it makes you it
makes you a chess they don't know tired
having multiple kids is tired to the
Bone can I get an amen amen there it is
amen hallelujah thank you Jesus this is
the Ry show create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life